[Music]
on this Monday night Canada in mourning
again after the deadly crash of a
snowbirds jet in BC the horror in the
air and the heroes on the ground we
basically just ran over the critical
clues caught on video our Robin Gill is
in Kamloops tonight fond memories of a
friend she was up for adventure and up
for learning and up for talking about
anything the life and loss of captain
Jen Casey
breaking news from the White House why
the u.s. president says he's taking a
drug that's not approved for use against
kovat 19 and multi-million dollar boosts
the Chinese president's promise to help
fight ko bid 19
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
their mission was to soar over the
country lifting the collective spirit of
the nation during the pandemic tonight
Canada's snowbirds are grounded and are
mourning one of their own operation
inspiration came to a crashing halt on
Sunday when one of the Jets plummeted to
the ground shortly after takeoff from
the airport in Kamloops BC an
investigation is now underway into what
went wrong the crash killed captain gen
Casey a public affairs officer but the
pilot Captain Richard MacDougall
survived a number of people were
watching the takeoff and taking videos
and those will likely play a role in the
investigation
it all happened less than a minute after
takeoff from Kamloops Airport shortly
before noon on Sunday everything looked
routine the two snowbirds were on route
to Comox BC the tooter jets flying
side-by-side on this shot at about 23
seconds in you can hear a slight pop in
the engine
a split second later one of the jets
peels away and gains altitude as he
starts to climb we call that a zoom and
he's trying to convert air speed into
altitude in aviation we see we say that
air speed his life altitude is life
insurance and so having that extra
altitude creates two options one is sort
out the problem along here further from
the ground and the second is to create
more space between the airplane and the
ground to a jack
it keeps rising until about 35 seconds
when it appears to stall and begins to
nosedive at 39 seconds you can see what
appear to be two ejections but no
visible sign of parachutes and about 41
seconds after takeoff
the Snowbird crashes into a residential
neighborhood the pilot landed on the
roof of a house remarkably no one on the
ground was injured neighbors rushed to
the scene to help Robin Gil is in
Kamloops BC tonight and has been talking
to some of them Robin
Don as you mentioned the plane went down
in a residential neighborhood just a few
minutes from here and that is why so
many neighbors were able to rush to the
scene some of them are nurses some of
them are paramedics and they're among
the many people here in Kamloops who
have dropped off flags and cards and
flowers in a very touching tribute to
the snowbirds because what this
community witnessed was very devastating
spectators on the ground knew within
seconds that something was wrong we
heard a big bang saw the two pilots
being ejected and then
we basically just ran over the plane hit
a house and burst into flames an elderly
couple lives in the home remarkably they
weren't hurt but the pilot landed on the
roof and suffered serious injuries
captain Richard MacDougall is one of the
coordinators for the snowbirds team
[Music]
according to colleagues the 34 year old
is well-trained with an affinity for
singing witnesses say he was asking
about his teammate while dealing with
his own pain he was on a stretching too
because he's complaining to back
injuries but he was he was wiggling his
toes and his fingers Phillips and her
mom a retired nurse rushed to the scene
to help that's when they noticed the
other member of the snowbirds in the
backyard her injuries were were likely
that impact and the this the ejection
seat was beside her so and I don't think
their parachutes opened at all no there
was nothing anyone could do to save
captain
Jennifer Casey she and McDougald often
flew together Casey was the public
affairs spokesperson for the snowbirds
and recently discussed a crash involving
the snowbirds
in Atlanta Georgia thankfully everybody
was able to walk away from that from
that incident the pilot captain Kevin
Damone grenier used his skills and
training to put the plane in an
unpopulated area and everybody was able
to walk away the day of the crash that
took her life the snowbirds faced delays
because of weather and according to one
pilot a technical problem all right sir
on the ground in Kamloops unfortunately
because of some electrical malfunctions
few of us had to come back early the
snowbirds jets are now grounded at the
airport in Kamloops the military has its
own investigative team looking into the
matter the precise circumstances leading
up to the crash are not known the crash
site has been secured by local law
enforcement and the immediate flight
safety response is being coordinated on
the ground by the teams flight safety
officers as we speak the memorial for
captain casey grows a community
heartbroken for a woman they didn't even
know obviously is very very sad that
this would have happened
in a time when they're trying to inspire
and keep the morale up of all Canadians
it's a tough day the Prime Minister and
his defense minister Harjit Sajjan have
expressed their condolences and they'd
like the rest of Canada are hoping to
get answers from the military
investigation that has been launched a
key witness though will be captain
mcdougal who did survive this crash but
he's still in hospital with very serious
injuries Donna right Robin Gillan
Kamloops BC thanks well the fact the
pilot survived gives investigators a big
advantage he will hopefully be able to
give them a first-hand account of every
second of that takeoff and crash our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
has been talking to people about the
investigation Mercedes who will lead it
Donna this will be led by the
Directorate of flight safety which is
part of the Air Force and they will do
this using air force experts as well as
experts if necessary from Transport
Canada to get involved in civil aviation
they conduct the activity investigation
whenever there is a military crash it's
not the Transportation Safety Board or
the civilian authorities but it's
essentially the same way of going about
it so they are going to be gathering
evidence on the ground they're going to
be interviewing those who witnessed the
crash
especially the pilot hoping that he
might be able to tell them what happened
or at least the sequence of events that
could give them some hints and of course
they'll also be looking at that video
that the rest of us have been trying to
determine why he suddenly loses power
and that's where you see him do that
zoom maneuver and where we just heard in
the press conference from leftenant
Colonel French that he ran out of
options and made the command decision
that they had to eject out of the
aircraft we should have an initial sense
of what they think happened within 30
days left tenant Colonel French said but
it could take up to a year for the
investigation to be completed
Mercedes ejection is what these pilots
train for it is a split-second decision
and it's what saved the pilots life in
this case we know it's happened before
in these Tudor jets how much of a factor
might the ejection seats be in the
investigation well it will certainly be
a factor and we learned a little bit in
this press conference when leftenant
Colonel French revealed that both people
had successfully ejected out of the
plane because that wasn't clear
watching it looked like there could be
two injection ejections but we weren't
completely sure the question will be did
the seats function as they were intended
to these are older seats so in newer
aircraft you can eject much lower to the
ground pilots tell me and it's much more
survivable these are older aircraft
they're not designed to save your life
at a low altitude and they will be
looking at whether that seat separated
properly and whether or not that was any
kind of a factor in captain Casey's
death it has been a factor in past
deaths of Snowbird pilots that there
have been malfunctions with the ejection
seats Donna Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
Thank You captain Jennifer Casey was a
proud member of the snowbirds team and a
proud Nova Scotian too we'll have more
on her and how she's being remembered a
little bit later as the military mourns
it's also dealing with a growing number
of cases of kovat 19 within its ranks
Global News has learned the number of
Canadian soldiers infected with the
virus has jumped to 14 43 others are now
in self-isolation
the troops were exposed after being
deployed to work in long-term care homes
in Ontario in Quebec in Quebec today
there are 707 confirmed new cases today
it is still the hardest hit province in
Canada but there is a reason for
cautious optimism though 34 new deaths
were reported in Quebec today that is
the lowest since mid-april next door in
Ontario the death toll has now surpassed
1900 as for daily new cases Ontario
reported a slight dip today 304 more
people have tested positive business
owners in Ontario are making some final
adjustments before they reopen tomorrow
Ontario will roll out phase 1 of its
plan to kick-start the economy after a
month-long shutdown we've set up cash
tests around the stores to ensure two
meters between every guest and customer
in addition to that we have virus
shields you'll kind of see throughout
this store the state of emergency was
declared in Ontario in mid-march from
tomorrow retail stores like this one
plus vehicle dealerships health services
and other recreation and sports
facilities have been given the green
light to reopen businesses must take
precautions though to keep customers and
staff safe Premier Doug Ford says
business
should only reopen if they are ready as
provinces begin to ease restrictions
there's a need to expand testing for
covet 19 in many places it's still
people with symptoms who get tested that
means people who may have the virus but
don't have any symptoms are not being
detected and could be spreading kovat 19
without knowing it Heather your ex west
reports on one provinces efforts to
gauge how many people are asymptomatic
and why that's key to preparing for a
possible second wave robin adair was
tested last week for kovat 19 even
though she had no symptoms and no known
exposure a couple of the supermarkets i
shop at in this neighborhood have had
cases um so you know i'm certainly aware
it's been in the neighborhood but none
that I'm aware of directly no Adair was
one of six thousand people to come
forward for testing after the province
announced last week that it would begin
screening community members with no
obvious symptoms for the disease in its
first week Alberta's asymptomatic
testing program tested 1,500 people and
found 50 cases that were positive
surveillance in the general community is
a very good idea as well especially now
because we can you know if you if
there's a signal that's available we
could jump on that very quickly to
prevent this from from spiraling out of
control and and infecting lots of people
Alberta's asymptomatic testing program
is only open to residents of the Calgary
region who have continued to work in the
community that's because most of the
provinces Kovan 19 cases have been from
this region provincial health officials
say it doesn't make sense to expand the
program province-wide
we really want to focus our testing
where we get the most clinical value and
so the broad-based testing across the
province is unlikely to yield a lot of
good clinical information surveillance
programs will become a key part of the
country's kovat 19 strategy in the weeks
ahead particularly as lock downs begin
to lift
well Alberta is the first to roll out
asymptomatic testing at a community
level other jurisdictions have used the
strategy to test for outbreaks among
high-risk populations like the homeless
as well as those working and living in
long-term care it's an expensive
investment but it's a very valuable
investment because it pays off and
Adair who works at a chorus owned radio
station the same company that owns
Global News says she wanted to be tested
for her co-workers sake her negative
test results giving her at least for the
time being some extra peace of mind
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
breaking news from the White House
coming up why the US president says he's
been taking a drug that's not approved
for use in treating Kovac nineteen plus
the day many Italians have been waiting
for
the US president Donald Trump made a
surprising admission today he says he's
taking hydroxychloroquine and has been
for several weeks
it's an anti-malarial drug Trump has
claimed it can cure or prevent Kovan 19
the thing is there is no scientific
proof of that in fact there is evidence
it can be harmful and can lead to heart
problems and even death
Jaxson Prosecco is with me from
Washington Jackson give us some context
where did the president admit to this
and why well Donna the admission came a
short time ago as Trump was actually
responding to reporters about that
whistleblower testimony from last week
in which a government scientist said he
was fired for objecting to the promotion
of this unproven kovat 19 treatment well
Trump continues to insist it is fully
effective he now claims without proof
that health care workers are taking it
widely as a preventative measure and
even though he himself does not have co
vid 19 he says he too has started taking
it the frontline workers many many are
taking it I happen to be taking it I
happen to be taking it my track record
I'm taking it hydroxychloroquine right
now yeah couple of weeks ago started
taking it because I think it's good I've
heard a lot of good stories so I have
been taking it for about a weekend for
about a week and a half at some point
every day I take a pill every day
at some point I'll stop what I'd like to
do is I'd like to have the cure and/or
the vaccine Jackson the FDA has warned
against using this drug outside of a
hospital setting what the president is
doing could be dangerous to him and to
those who follow his example why is he
doing this well it could be a very
simple attempt to change the channel or
to prove his critics wrong remember
Trump was actively promoting this drug
and then sort of backed away from it as
those studies started to question its
efficacy really there were kind of three
scenarios at play here scenario one is
that Trump is in fact taking the drug
and risking the side effects
number two is that he's being given a
placebo or a very low dose by his
doctors and number three is that he's
not taking it at all knowing that
there's no way for the public to
actually tell if he is or he isn't
at the bottom line here is that it's
really a distraction from a pandemic
that has now killed 90,000 people in
this country and Donna it also speaks to
the broader issue that keeps coming up
time and time again which is that Trump
is prioritizing his own advice against
that of scientists and doctors Jackson
Prosecco in Washington Thanks ahead a
stunning reversal and a new promise from
China
life is slowly returning to a version of
normal in Italy restrictions are easing
after ten weeks of lockdown Italians can
now CIPA morning cappuccino at cafes and
eat a slice of pizza with their partner
church services are back but with
physical distancing in place Italy was
the first European country to impose a
nationwide lockdown
a big change of heart from China today
President Xi Jingping told a World
Health Organization meeting he now
supports an investigation into the
origins of the corona virus pandemic
pressure was mounting over 120 countries
have joined the call for an independent
investigation
the US has accused China and the w-h-o
of trying to conceal the outbreak
crystal commencing reports we must be
frank about one of the primary reasons
this outbreak run out of control the
United States the current epicenter of
the pandemic is doubling down on its
position that the World Health
Organization helped China mislead the
world there was a failure by this
organization to obtain the information
that the world needed and that failure
cost many lives they misled us last
month the White House froze funding
payments to the agency ultimately
questioning the effectiveness of the w8
show she Jing ping again defended his
country's actions saying all along China
has acted with openness transparency and
responsibility against the blame game
backdrop a normally bureaucratic meeting
of the wh o--'s governing body became
somewhat dramatic in the end the w-h-o
agreed to an independent review of its
management to the pandemic even as the
vast majority of member nations
demonstrated support for the agency
German Chancellor Angela Merkel's saying
the World Health Organization is the
legitimate global institution where all
threads come together the Director
General has been deflecting questions
about politics for weeks focusing
instead on the virus itself the risk
remains high and we have a long road to
travel to Jai
Korea says the w-h-o needs legal powers
under current rules the agency can't
enter a country uninvited to investigate
and it can't compel governments to act
China now says it will allow for an
impartial investigation once the
pandemic is under control and has
pledged two billion dollars in support
money that will fill the financial hole
left by the u.s. crystal go dancing
Global News London
next remembering captain Jennifer Casey
how she inspired on the ground and in
the skies
the snowbirds are ambassadors for the
Canadian Armed Forces they're a small
close-knit group based in Moose Jaw
Saskatchewan formation flying takes
precision training and trust they cannot
function if they don't work as a team
and captain Jen Casey was a key member
of that team she was a former journalist
and a proud Nova Scotian as Ross Lord
reports she made friends across the
country at age 35 Jennifer Casey better
known as Jen did more than her share of
living first Casey was a dedicated radio
reporter and producer mostly in her home
city of Halifax she went from serving
your community to serving her country
joining the military as a public affairs
officer with the snowbirds acrobatic
team she flew with every mission for the
past year and a half a lover of sports
and music friends remember Casey as
bright and witty with a positive
attitude that rubbed off on others she
was up for adventure and up for learning
and up for talking about anything but it
was never a serious sight it was always
a happy good-natured person and it was
just easy to make fast friends with her
her death joins a string of Nova Scotia
related tragedies with a particular
cruelty after the mass murders that
killed 22 people in April Navy sailor
Abigail Cobra was among those honoring
the victims
then she and five other military members
based in Halifax were killed in the
crash of a cyclone helicopter as a
gesture of comfort the snowbirds
conducted a special flyover in Nova
Scotia
captain Casey flying with the team over
her home province now she's gone leaving
friends and former colleagues stunned
2020 is a year I'd like to forget and
we're not even halfway there yet the
crash that took Casey's life is also
painful in Moose Jaw Saskatchewan the
home of the snowbirds
I think it's time that we can take this
opportunity to show them our gratitude
and and rally around them and let them
know that we care and love love them
very much
from Casey's professor some consolation
in the tragedy she was also doing
something she really loved and so that
doesn't make it any easier but at the
same time it also says she was she was
where she wanted to be at the time the
military says it's making plans with
Casey's family for events to mark her
passing Ross lore Global News Halifax
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm doner fries and we leave you
tonight soaring with the snowbirds this
footage was taken Saturday as the
snowbirds flew from Alberta to Kamloops
BC one day before captain Casey's last
flight their mission was to inspire
Canadians and salute those on the front
lines of the pandemic now the whole
country is saluting the snowbirds
sharing in their grief and looking
forward to when they take to the skies
again thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
you
[Music]